no i was wrong i had to put this thing
on one more time but
i'm me so yeah of course i was wrong
[Music]
hey everybody i wrapped up my re-watch
of the 11th doctor's time
it closed out overdue doctor who review
and
that just leaves me with one thing to do
give my opinion of the top 10 11th
doctor stories reminder i do count two
parters as a single story so any two
partners in here only take up one
slot we've got 10 of these to get
through so
let's get going number 10
the day of the doctor even though this
is a multi-doctor story i am still going
to consider it an 11th doctor story
because it happened during his
tenure now i actually bounced back and
forth as to whether
this number 10 spot was going to go to
this one or name of the doctor i'd like
them both for not
vastly dissimilar reasons at the end of
the day i like this
the more celebratory feel for the day of
the doctor and that
edged it out just a little bit and while
i feel like i would have liked to spend
more time
with john hurt's doctor than we got in
this
he's still good in the part tenant and
smith play off each other very well
we have kate stewart back and she's
doing good in it i love the use of billy
piper in this
i love tom baker as the curator
there's just a lot to like in this and
it does feel like they really did try
for a full
proper celebration for the 50th
anniversary and especially that closing
shot with
all the doctors that we've had up to
that point yeah
yeah that's uh that's some good stuff
number nine
asylum of the daleks i'm pretty sure
when i did my series seven
ranking that i put name of the doctor
over this so it might seem strange that
this is higher than name of the doctor
which effectively is the unofficial
number 11.
but um this is just how things felt
this this time around i think the thing
was when i did the series seven
ranking i was putting more weight into
name of the doctor as a culmination of
the season up to that point whereas for
this list
i'm taking them a bit more as entities
in and of themselves
yeah sure let's go with that i'm not
inconsistent yes i am
but anyways asylum of the daleks is an
episode that i actually
like a lot i like the feel and the vibe
to it but i also feel that the emotional
resonance rings true at least it does
for me i know it doesn't work for
everybody
but it was solid for me and i
like the the banter that goes on i like
this iteration of clara
quite a bit i really do uh enjoy
oswin that's uh that's a lot of fun for
me
and i just like the way that it kind of
barrels forward just starting with this
insane premise of
the daleks are gonna fire the doctor at
a planet full of insane daleks
yeah okay i'm on board for that number
eight
two-parter the impossible astronaut
in the day of the moon well i am sorry
to say that
on the re-watch the silence overall in
terms of
looking at them as something that was
around for a decent chunk of
um smith's tenure they didn't quite
pay off the way i would have liked that
said their first official appearance
here
it's really good stuff i love this i
love the concept of the silence i love
the look of the silence i love the way
that they are defeated
by tying that order you should kill us
all on site
to that one clip from the moon landing
that
and and for me it tracks that like
everybody's going to see that eventually
even as humans go off
and into outer space if they are taught
history at any point
they will see this clip and that makes a
lot of sense to me so it's a clever
solution to a really
intimidating foe we've got river in this
who
does really good work and
while a lot of the stuff that was set up
the payoffs in later episodes didn't
feel quite right i still feel
this is a strong story in and of itself
even though the
dangling threads weren't tied up later
as much as i would have liked
number seven a good man goes to war
this one this is a nice roller coaster
of an episode because starts out
amy's captured doctor shows up and
basically
waltzes all over this army that thought
they were ready for them but so
was not and i love that i love his
confidence amelia pond
get your coat and that's fantastic and
then to realize
that it was trapped even further
and that madam cavarian expected him to
get this far
and that these gathering of allies and
everything he went through he still
didn't accomplish everything he came
there to do because he came to rescue
amy
and the baby he got amy lost the child
and the impact of that i think
that karen gillum sells it really well
both the
terror at the realization of it and then
the anger directed initially at river
song
and then the revelation about river
those things just kind of tumble on top
of each other and it
is it is a wonderful roller coaster of
emotions that for me
pays off really well number six
the god complex first off
creepy setting i love when doctor who
gets creepy
like legitimately because there are
there are some things about doctor who
that whether or not they'll creep you
out is very subjective and it depends on
whether or not
certain things inherently kind of like
are a push on your buttons a little bit
but i feel like they really sold this
whole thing with this
hotel in these endless corridors they
keep reshaping but they all look
the same and this twisting of
faith into something that you know
you're terrified of something
then you're not and you praise the thing
that took that fear away and it
feeds on that to consume you
that's a wonderfully twisted concept
the fact that it's a minotaur is maybe
slightly on the nose but
i'm prepared to roll with it i think the
execution on this is just terrific
number five amy's choice
two reasons especially on a re-watch
i've come to really appreciate
how much this helps establish and firm
up
the relationship between amy and rory
and we get the dream master
and i love the dream master bring him
back
like he he's a construct from the
doctor's mind
you can figure out a way to get him to
manifest again please
oh he's so good he's just this vicious
gross little
gah he's just twisting the knife into
everybody pushing everybody's buttons
including the doctors but the doctor
also clocks onto who he is right away
and i love that moment as well the back
and forth the
the discombobulation the disorientation
of everything going on is
really well played and the dream master
is just the icing on the cake
number four the girl
who waited another uh amy centric
episode
karen gillan sells the hell out of this
the bitterness the frustration the
anger at being left behind
not only at having been left behind but
being left behind
being convinced that they were going to
come for her
and they didn't for decades
and the way that kind of eats at her
and gives us the amy that we see and
she sells that so she had to if she
couldn't sell that this episode was not
going to work
but then also in addition to that arthur
darville's rory really does a fantastic
job showing the conflict that he's so
happy to see her
but it's not the enemy he knows but he's
still prepared to love her
it's so well put together and then at
the end when they have to shuttle damie
out and the doctor
pulls such a dick move
putting it back on rory saying okay
there can only be one in here you decide
oh again in character
so i get it and it works but man
jerk move wow
and it's tense and it's
unsettling and it's sad
it's really good this one it's a really
good amy centric episode
number three the doctor's wife
fun the fun of the idea of
the tardis in being embodied in this
woman the doctor gets to have
banter with the fun of them running
around and her
eccentricities and her i like biting
it's like kissing except someone wins
and all these odd little moments but
then also the doctor
having such phenomenal lines as
when house threatens him and he says
fear me i've killed hundreds of time
most egos fear me i've killed them all
and first of all house this disembodied
voice and a glowing light that should
not be intimidating that should not work
as a villain but it
so totally does michael sheen really
sells the voice on that it works
fantastically and as it messes with amy
and rory
which really does a lot to give you
satisfaction when he gets taken down at
the end oh this is just uh this is just
such a satisfying episode number two
the 11th hour very first outing
for the 11th doctor and i will continue
to contend that
short of an unearthly child this is the
best
first adventure for a doctor that
we've gotten because it accomplishes
everything it needs to
it establishes who this doctor is it
establishes who amy is
it establishes how their relationship
is going to function and how it became
what it was
we don't suddenly have to wait and see
what sort of relationship develops
because amy waited for him for a decade
plus she already has a dynamic and is
already knows what she thinks of him
she doesn't have to figure him out she
has completely
decided what she thinks of this guy so
even we have what feels like an
established dynamic
in a matter of minutes and getting to
see all of this come together and pull
together in what is also a really fun
episode and the power of getting to see
him finally in that bow tie
hello i'm the doctor yeah
yeah you are it's such a
masterfully done first outing for a
doctor because
it sells him and his companion
and the vibe of this new series and this
new era
so well it does a phenomenal job
doesn't quite take the top spot top spot
is going to go to vincent and the doctor
because as i have gone back
and rewatched this episode and as i have
gotten older as we tend to do
the depth and the understanding with
which
this puts a lens on depression
not only those who have it but
sending a message of hope to the loved
ones
of someone with it because
that ending is so
important that they take
vincent to the future to see the
impact of his work and to understand
what he means to people
but it doesn't change that he dies by
his own hand and it still happens at the
same point
because
sometimes what is behind depression
is going to be the end of someone
but that doesn't mean that it isn't
worth
being kind and adding
to someone's pile of good things
and again the re-watch has granted me a
lot more insight into this with things
like
the blind invisible monster
this haphazard destructive thing
that only vincent can see no one else
can see the fight
can see the the creature the beast that
he is
fighting only he can see it they just
see him flailing madly
trying to fend it off
but it also doesn't even mean him harm
but its existence is harmful
it is uh an embodiment of depression
it's not the last time that doctor who
will do it and
when doctor who has decided to tackle
these sorts of things i feel the show
has done it very well and this episode
does it masterfully anchored by a
phenomenal
performance for vincent and
obviously also great performances from
matt smith from karen gillan but
tony karan has vincent
is the heart and soul of this and he
nails it just with looks
this is an episode that is powerful it
is important and i think it's something
that
a lot of people will benefit from seeing
even if they aren't doctor who fans
so that's my number one
for the 11th doctor what do you think of
my list
what would your list be whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about usual stuff like
subscribe i have patreon i have
twitter and social media and instagram
etc etc links in the description
hop to it or don't
end of the day you're the council
i'm just running the meetings
i got these uh specifically to be able
to
have more accurate glasses to cosplay
this doctor as
i think i'll be wearing them outside
this thing though in any case
this council is a jerk
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye